dr. Emily Morris is coming well madam
she's one of the premier sexologists in
the country I know you're like you've
got a doctorate I do insects I do sex
therapy
I'm a sexologist it's a human sexuality
yeah so I have a doctorate in human
sexuality terrible at it yes many times
I was just having bad sex I was like I
feel like sex could be a lot better than
it is yeah so he did the research I did
the research I just gotta be better than
it is what was wrong with it you know I
just thought well at the time I didn't
know now I've been studying here for 14
years I was like oh I get it but then I
was like a lot of women I think you were
raised thinking that men knew all the
answers to like what I needed in bed
because I didn't know my own body what
made me feel good it was all about
pleasing men and I was disappointed and
then people would always say Oh last
night I had amazing sex I was like I
want to have the best sex in my life so
I thought I want to figure this out is
very important is it not communication
isn't a vacation here I'm serious called
sex with Emily Monday through Friday
8:00 to 10:00 p.m. Eastern over on Starz
channel 109 and this is a Karen Feehan
and Claire Parker they're both the
fabulous comedian yes yes fine hi guys
hi no it's for having me this is a
question that's been brought up okay
seven minutes it's enough right we all
get to decide that's right if your
partner is cool with it she is
[Laughter]
you should get off early
okay well average sexy we'll see
laughing 12 minutes
typically a 12-minute probably check
that research how do they know like they
like did study as people filled up
research like Claire the people do
research
anybody that's why I know in fact so
it's 12 months of intercourse or of like
foreplay and inner hopefully read at all
but it's everything because we play well
right yeah that works for you but for a
lot you seem happy yeah why not though
could we call your wife because I mean
no it sounds good but when most women
need between 20 and 40 minutes orgasms
porn on the cab over so that I get my 20
minutes I start early are too scared to
talk about things we need to warm up it
doesn't have to be like technically
foreplay where you're like touch it you
could send a sexy text watch porn warm
yourself up you know what I did
[Laughter]
yesterday I shoveled the driveway
warming up so that way she's like oh he
shoveled the driveway this is getting me
excited that way five and a half she
said you do a masculine like I said then
she didn't even actually asked me to
shovel the driveway she looked out the
window I was also scraping off her cars
but that's hot acts of service that's
what the love language love language
trap do I know mine yes I would help you
right now just want to do this we should
all figure out our lovely
because don't you know even in love but
even in the workplace and then will you
tell me what my juice I can help you so
do you guys love languages do you know
there's five okay so you guys have done
one of them is sucking dick that's gyms
[Laughter]
I'm sorry going there are five love
language okay so there's five there's
words of affirmation you look hot today
and then you can tell me out of these
five out of these five there's typically
one that's like yes that makes me feel
loved and then there's like a second one
there's like a you know okay there's
like a so there's words of affirmation
you look so happy oh my god and then
there's a physical touch like you want
to be hugged you want to be touched
there's types of service scraping the
ice off the I like cuz g-spot is just me
gag where's love languages when she
stops talking every day for like thank
you for helping me not personally out
them I'm not like here you go but I know
okay okay we have access service
the third we have that saying sexy
things we have a physical touch we have
acts of service like a sexy thing is it
had to be a texture can it be like not
like there is no sexy thing as a lovely
like like that for me the same [ __ ] if I
tell a woman like I want to make you
help you have a comer works for me okay
what else we got gifts gifts like we go
out Saturday night it's just us we don't
have our phones on we're just we have to
be together I don't like that I want my
phone how do you so what do you think
yours is okay I feel the most love like
would you like you want to hear from
someone I think it's words of
affirmation yeah because you just need
approval I'm shaking I love you love
sexting I love being told that I'm funny
and pretty and hot and smart all the
compliment it's rare but it happens
I get off on mean it or not comments
because it's still attention in that
sense like they're words that like
denigration are still like thinking
about me so I just twisted him like wow
they're so obsessed with me they hate me
I'm Stevie shall be me no fat chick it
was the best like oh that's right your
math was a main site which was that my
bird is worried about me why'd you back
up it shows like glitter the show my big
fat fabulous life oh my big fat right
she insulted the girl you think your
love language is also words no yes you
like to guess what's your gifts because
I'm always disappointed
by gifts when I hear gifts I think money
okay yeah there's but there's always
more money you know I mean someone gives
you a thousand dollars I'm like well
okay what's your love language Jim um
Spanish I would say the the dirty the
dirty sucking
and and and dirty talk words of
affirmation you did great today awesome
show you're hilarious
yeah choke on my dick yeah as long as it
said in a gruff voice good because then
here's why they're important is because
with your partner sometimes we don't
feel loved and it's like often we give
love the way we want to receive it so
like the [ __ ] relationships because
you're like I like so mine's words of
affirmation and physical touch I'm like
just tell me I'm hot and [ __ ] me like
what's the problem there that's right I
don't need gifts right I don't even want
to spend time with you maybe there yeah
so with them back because say something
really nice to me and then I like I'm
actually going out right now and he
literally cuddles me all night and I'm
just I sever it's so great no you're
sleeping cuddling is nice but a time to
sleep yeah horrible elegant hand on your
back kiss me I like that about the
course of a night oh that's romantic oh
my god I was like this is torture
I was very watered I'd make out kisses
the kids that wanted to be makeout you
know what I mean and I'm like dude throw
it in my comment breath get the [ __ ] out
of here yeah what sure this is Troy Kwan
he is uh fairly promiscuous what's your
love language probably sex with minimal
communication raised a friend it's Troy
Kwan don't talk to me Troy Kwan is a
friend and I really worry about it black
and I need you to get to the bottom of
something his healthy turn-ons he really
went through a bad breakup recently and
it's the reason it was bad is because it
took a long time and I was like why is
this taking so long and in a moment of
confidence he told us that the reason
that his breakup was taking so long is
because the person that he was
a relationship with would cry because
the relationship was ending which is you
know it's an emotional thing and he
every single time this person cried he
would become physically erect and he
would have sex with her he likes because
he was turned on by her crying prettiest
when I was crying and he made me cry a
lot and I was like I wonder if that was
part of it so it became this horrible
cycle where she's like well we're not
broken up because he just we had sex and
then the next day break up with her
again and then she'd cry and then they'd
have sex again
am i miss representing anything Troy not
at all first of all I'm a broken man in
some way have you ever heard that before
yeah I think it's really hard to detach
from someone that we love no not in the
like concern getting turned on by the
tears - have you heard there was more to
it than just here it wasn't like the
second the drop came out it was more the
emotional attachment with her well yeah
that was strong but I mean for comedic I
get it the tears but it was more like
why would you become erect when she was
crying
exactly she is and now it's like you
know more tears no more [ __ ] no no we
we barely talk okay because then he went
and told this story on the air and he's
doing it again right now you're out some
dude I'm like don't listen but why am i
okay with some dude Emily why not what
else am I supposed to do right what can
Troy do the next time he's in a
relationship and he's trying to break up
with this chick and she keeps crying and
he's in one of these neverending cycle
well hopefully if he learns from this
and takes some time to heal Troy don't
jump right into another relationship
right now and figure out I'm sorry
pretty here's the best things you
deserve a breakup like what did I learn
from this past relationship what did I
like about it what didn't I
like and then when I'm looking for a new
partner what won't I ever do again so
there must have been signs I felt like
you're Pickers broken right you want any
that might happen true I think
everything's broken I've never met
anybody that's I've never met anybody
that's learned less from his mistakes
than true yeah
he literally learned something yeah when
it comes to women he learns nothing from
previous experience not a baby this is
the time you can now that you know there
comes a point in our life we all say
look I might pick our Pickers broken
right like you keep picking the same a
huge market right now yeah so I think
for you would be interesting if you
don't want if you actually are saying to
me us right now you know what I don't
want to have that same experience again
and again then you just stop dating
right now if you are oh yeah and then
you're like literally write this [ __ ]
down or go to therapy and you're like
what worked what I love about it what I
did not and then you go some house
you're like oh this is toxic this
doesn't feel good anymore then you don't
jump right back in eventually eventually
I think we all stop repeating some of
the things the picker gets fixed you
probably died in a bad relationship I
don't know I told my ex I'd rather just
die alone than be miserable I don't you
said that just a flower just kill
yourself now why would you say she asked
him why he's waiting why wouldn't he
just kill himself today I don't
relationships I don't know I feel like
you what is your type like a physical
type or thank you house well well the
crying thing is because I love strong
women like I love you like freakin
Alexei Alexei strong women vulnerable
it's not the greatest good but the
crying thing is we're breaking is like
questionable it's something like
sometimes we I always say be the person
you want to find so you're dating women
who are really strong because you don't
feel that you're strong Jim is the
person he wants to find from the waist
put on a dress and get the camera ideas
like a g-spot locator absolutely
- but it's not really a spot it's an
area I can help you find if you really
want yeah okay
so have you had your clitoral orgasm
okay you're sure done clitoris pressure
and then GZ here's the problem with the
g-spot we often think that a piñar you
with men okay we often think a penis is
going to find it and that doesn't happen
for only 20% of women
your shoe's crack open the Bruce I'm
sorry doctor okay a clitoral orgasm
knock it off knock it out cuz then
you're like all turned on and dental
areas and Gore stimulated or but I woman
I have a toy I was there's some toys
that are awesome that just like the
g-spot the we-vibe rave is a toy that is
this amazing G it's a it's a vibrator
you can control it with your phone and
like you just use it you go in there
phone that would actually very much turn
me on exactly like you can have a phone
and you could have the toy you could be
like go up go down and I could Twitter
and the TV and you could tweet tweet
yeah so you just want to like go in
it's like - it's like two inches at an
instant half inside it is - come hither
motion towards your belly button come
and then you'll cry pressure to it like
pressure it's not like a which is why
doesn't work because men think they just
have to like Ram you like that squirting
is all the rage every girl does it you
tell when a girl needs a pounding doctor
what do you think our friend Jim Norton
can do to help find love you know
Valentine's Days tomorrow he's looking
he's looking for love in all the wrong
places
I don't know I don't know honey tell me
come like that just I just want a nice
person okay but then also it'll like are
you looking for a monogamous
relationship on my end yeah okay I'm
you're like from like meaning that she's
been honest to me I'm just saying what I
would like in a perfect world I wouldn't
mind monogamous well I mean at this
point you've been monogamous in your
past yeah I have yeah so you're looking
for how you find what do you look at
where are you going to find the women
right now a lot of yes Instagram
lines there yeah wherever you need to
find it yeah how are you like dating are
you so they don't okay and you go out
what happens you're just are they the
right kind of going on dates with women
who live in other states these are going
fly them in for the weekend don't do
that issues no sense they're not here
you can't seem all the time there's it
but there are so many people if you meet
somebody and they live in another state
and they're gonna and like you you like
them I mean I do stand-up so I meet them
at shows or I talk to them because yeah
that you're meeting through the power
dynamic of their your face exactly first
of all the only way I meet them
retweeted me women like that cuz this
way they know that there's no
explanation needed
you know you but you know who you are
and not be a fan that's what I was when
I met say maybe try to find some women
in New York there were plenty woman I
know but like flying him in the show I
love the power dynamic what am I like I
hear a lot of like oh I'm just paying
their rent no don't give them the money
and the whole thing no no my papers rent
okay where it may be not yet who's
paying my rent ship so you fire in it's
hot and she leaves it's hot again and
then you never really get that depth
than the intimacy if you're into that
kinda but that's not replacing New York
women but that's not like I'm saying
like I'm not gonna take New York right
because I'm dating this girl from
[ __ ] San Francisco or Cleveland it's
just one of those things if you meet
somebody they're trying to fly in some
coos yeah exactly I mean sometimes I get
a little bored and then your couch
[Applause]
no it's just one way to do it it's not
the only way oh it's good to diversify
your tactics I got it yeah really I
don't know I mean what kind of chick you
want something was nice yes small right
nice smart
that's a humor compatible you can't even
put it in what like what is it I don't
know what make what makes somebody
compatible what Pat was your Pat you a
pattern that hasn't worked are you
honest with the people you meet about
what you want are you like right away
like yeah pretty much not always but you
feel things out of course right like do
you say what I think what a lot of us do
is was just fun going out and dating and
meeting people but it's cool to be like
this is what I want I'm looking for
monogamous relationship or not somebody
that was somebody does that talk with
you too early is boring
there's nothing worse than when you're
out having a good time like I listen
this is what up yeah it's the second
best relationships end was there a
pattern yeah I mean it really depends I
mean a lot of times I was unfaithful or
a lot of times we just you just stopped
liking each other or you just meet up
there's a million reasons maybe you want
to be an open relationship and just be
honest about it
there's so many people yours that are
actually and really healthy open
relationship totally works
you navigate almost balanced and the
least anxious when I was in an opener
you did right yeah but didn't you hate
though if you were out with the guy if
all of a sudden he's texting other
people when you're together aren't you
talking to somebody you're sleeping with
Wenberg if you want to go out with some
buddies hey what are you doing Tuesday
all I'm busy Tuesday and then I'm like
well if you're busy going out with
somebody I'm not gonna you're on the
road a ton so you could say you're only
like going we're only going to go and do
other people with we're out of town yeah
you don't know about it your rules and
boundaries but not like rules are like
hang me a picture with you at another
chick that were the rule would you go
out on the road and be like like you'd
have a moment of like let's say you
don't hook up after your show I'd want
to jerk off with somebody right and
you're sitting there you see
excuse me - you're sitting there going
like you're worried that this chick that
you're hanging out with us hooking up
with somebody else while you're on the
road and nobody is interested in you
after your show yeah I just go back to
the hotel by myself yeah because a lot
of times on the road I don't [ __ ] around
I just don't I just go back you just fly
after no if you meet somebody you don't
just you meet first you don't just
[ __ ] me the first thing we can't know
this guy tried to [ __ ] me first date on
Monday he know Oh wasn't that big sure
was
how was Tuesday on the first day it
probably means I'm never gonna [ __ ] on I
like to know immediately whether or not
I'm interested in having sex good I can
go on like a hundred more days with you
and still be like it's just not gonna
happen but my sex I wish I had just had
sex with a guy on Saturday night and I
think that cloud was still that yeah you
need like a day - I needed security you
need like a Sabbath yeah I get it yeah I
mean so I feel like you meet them and
you don't even know if there's chemistry
but then you fly them in then they're
here are they staying with you and then
you have a whole thing yeah I've had
people say there's always work out like
let me just say this the open
relationship thing they practice like
rigorous honesty like people I know they
have like their rules it's not like
you're like randomly sorry I'm not
coming home tonight baby like that's
crazy-making yeah I thought you were so
you're literally you share calendars you
know like you're going out with someone
Thursday night so am i this is what's
happening you decide if you want to hear
all the details
it's not like it's so like don't you
want to be able to just meet somebody
and go like yeah I want to rules like
you literally write it down it was fun
like that's what's hot about cheating
yeah it's like doing bad stuff and like
sneaking around yeah yeah being Nordics
what you sacrifice when you're in an
open relationship really you know yeah i
hook up with a lot of people in
relationships because I get scared of
emotional commitments like they work for
me and I was talking about the guy two
summers ago and he was telling me he
loved me and he's like this isn't
cheating I'm in an open relationship I'm
like she did not sign up for you to be
in love with someone like this is
cheating your dad's a micro machine guy
I know exactly who you're talking about
a man who talks extremely quickly fast
talk Claire yeah I think that you shall
quickly stop me so it's like how many
words gonna get in before people are
like shut up you know been spayed yet
it's always the best way to make as many
points as you can just to shout as many
words as possible in a short session so
Jim I mean rush I'm okay how do you see
fun yeah we're crushing you yeah I don't
know sometimes yes sometimes depends on
who I'm dating I mean it really does
there's no rule for that when I'm in a
relationship and I'm happy it's it's
nice but what's true but it goes bad
it's awful right yeah like all of us I
understand that that's wrong I mean
here's the thing about open or not open
it is more about communication like I
don't think that we're so afraid of
saying what we actually really want and
you'd be so surprised to find that
people are cool like they might want the
same thing but we don't know because
we're like I have to pretend that I'm a
nag miss but I actually want to cheat
and I know what you're saying about
cheating can be a thrill but I'm like uh
perform cheater I used to cheat how do
you reform in my 20s I always cheat yeah
be traveling abroad and like I'll [ __ ]
you weren't China like it doesn't knows
if I'll see you again or whatever I
would cheat but that never got caught
same guy I only like guy hot but I
didn't I am like the queen of denying do
you I can deny but the thing is that I
realize well why am I do it like why
can't I just be honest cuz to be it
wasn't the thrill of cheating I wasn't
like so psyched it was like I like man
like I'd meet someone there's chemistry
one of sex I wanna do it and then I
think then I would feel bad kind of not
as bad as I probably shouldn't did you
feel bad or were you like it that you're
supposed to feel bad this is the part
where I almost was like this is the part
now I was like I would feel bad but it
was usually towards the end of the
relationship I think I'm have one foot
out the door and then I thought well why
don't I just experiment because here's
the problem we all make every single
person who dates is that we this culture
is that we have sex with someone
and it's great and then we're like well
we've had sex a few times let's nail
this down and commit and then we'll
figure out in the next year if we love
each other won't torture each other and
kill each other why not admit that like
I'm gonna sleep with a few people Oh
tell people like I'm dating right now
I'm dating so how many but I am dating
I'm not ready to commit yet and then you
get to kind of taste bunch of other
people and figure it out and then you
can decide after a few months six months
whatever oh this person I actually want
to develop something with and then you
move on but we're all so secretive about
it and we nail it down right away and
you'll [ __ ] know anybody after
sleeping with them and then what
happened the reason why we do that is
because especially women we get attached
we have an orgasm and that oxytocin I
don't I never come cuz I am the only
person who's ever made me [ __ ] and at
this point like I don't think I could
love another person is so osteo oxytocin
dumped on myself do you think that's
independent to orgasms and his
personality is pure trash and I can't
wait to see him again
oh really I just he's garlic is terrible
he's not charming he's not smart he's
not witty he's stupid any be tweeted you
gorgeous that was Monday okay but like I
just like I don't know good dick we'll
just keep you hooked dick-notized like
he's not your guy we don't do this
enough we don't think like he's the guy
that gonna [ __ ] it not daylight I was
gonna come over here I forget night when
I'm on the Upper West Side why not like
that's big sense of you friends like
that like this the friend I watched the
game with this is the friend I talked to
and it all seems so complicated women
are not better cheating because women
underestimate their boyfriends women all
think they're smarter than my boy had so
many good I'm like by four doesn't look
at my phone I'm like you really don't
understand boyfriend's boyfriends are
better at lying to themselves and to you
about it because they're afraid of
losing you it might had I'd be like well
he's so paranoid about me cheating on
him that he probably wouldn't cheat on
me cuz why is he so scared of me and now
I look back and go
that's why I like somebody and I'm
obsessed I don't want to cheat on him
and I'm so scared maybe you won't cheat
on him cuz I get in relationships I
don't know how to break up and then I
date someone for four years that I
didn't even like to begin right yeah I
mean I don't want I feel like if I like
somebody I feel like I could be good for
as much as you talk I feel like you
would know how to break up with
something yeah it's harder though cuz
it's emotion so it's like the emotions
and it's really been committed and being
honest and being muscle yeah it's hard
to be vulnerable for sure it's not so
much easier just to be to not care so
are you what she are you single right
now are you in an open relationship or
you close yeah and is that by choice yes
yes you made a conscious effort look
whatever insecurities come out in the
way you take that question that's on
everybody else no insecurities I mean
I'm not no I don't I really don't I
don't Aaron on the other hand is ripe
with Oh a million insecurities but not
about me saying I'm single I love but
I've always loved beings like become
very independent but I love having
people in my life but right now I'm yeah
I was dating someone for like a year and
a half we ended it what happened I just
wanted different things
what did you want um I didn't want
children Oh frame could take a baby to
term yeah orgasms first I'm like Morgan
do just like it's me do you know I mean
I have you help show them how you orgasm
you just go oh look I tell you babe
here's how it works when how it drives
I've had guys that have come close and I
get freaked out and I don't do that
Missy is what I do have to do you have
to bridge it where you masturbate in
front of the person and you have them
there maybe they're participating a
little bit
Yasim with them in the world people want
a girl through a washy masturbate that's
how I will teach someone like as she's
masturbating I'll say sexy things what
type of stuff Gary talk give it to me
show me you're gushing I'm ten for ten
that's amazing
think about mutual masturbation is like
a huge if you can't have orgasms with a
partner or you just want to learn how
your partner gets off if you're lying
next to him you're like oh it's twofer
right you're like oh my god that's so
hot it's show visually you're like oh
look how you're getting off and then
you're like oh I didn't know that he
puts his hand on his balls and over the
tip when he's doing that so oh that's
what I'll do next time whatever do you
think when somebody can't have an orgasm
with their partner the issue is like in
the vulnerability how this that it goes
beyond sexual therapy and just needs
cognitive therapy now I don't bring up
anybody in particular
everybody needs therapy 20% of women
orgasm during intercourse during penile
penetration but yet in everything we see
in movies and television it's oh my god
they fall into the bed they roll over
and he bangs around crazy acts used to
call my vibrator my dil-don't you
infuriate me because I'm like do you
have no idea what's making me come there
and like yeah like it gave himself so
much credit I felt like that like I
missed his dick but I didn't like that's
not what this is right no um here's the
thing I think it partners you showed him
that it Kate I used to show my expert
Michael it was all the time and I think
he must have read an article once that
he just like really internalized coz he
would just immediately move his hand I'd
be like where were you don't like he
didn't why do you think I'm lying to you
right now
That's not me before and I've just like
claps at them like a dog Karen Karen
keeps a like a water spritzer bottle no
you're right you're right you handle it
well thank you go back go back go back
yeah it's good but we don't know here's
the thing and we're all different so
everyone's body is different i just
pounded up rarely works the pounding
always were sexy and motor you can fake
it too so you don't notice that I
haven't come once and I don't think they
did they like what they don't know this
is why we have to add this what I do all
day every day like I gotta educate we
kept we had zero sex education right
first kids and adults and we're all like
walking around like I have no idea but I
saw it and porn and this happened and so
I believe that they want to please us
right you want them to have real orgasms
not fake ones yeah
she's lying for daddy exactly she wants
daddy to pay more attention to her do
you like that one guys refer to
themselves as daddy do I like it yeah
yeah guys do that she pads on the guy in
the moment right into it I can get into
it okay I know there's not like one
thing that I have I'm like if we get
into a vibe it's situation situation we
better be older excuse me guys to be
older necessarily know I had my
ex-boyfriend was young and he was like
call me daddy okay he said call me daddy
daddy but he was like my little girl
because you were like I don't want to
have children
yeah exactly
okay she's gonna call you daddy the baby
and I'm calling gets all [ __ ]
confusing
do you like young guys or older guys
guys yeah I thought about that it's more
like is there a connection right I need
to call you his little girl it's pretty
common I guess hot it can be I never
thought it was hot but then with him it
was hot I would say I took you up with a
guy who was a literal father which was
like the first for me and I just think
I'm not appreciating that father of like
a like a twelve-year-old girl you show
me her picture and she was so pretty
like I was insecure about I liked it I
felt threatened by her but the guy has a
12 year old and then he's like saying
call me daddy and you're like I don't
want to do that start off with call me
they call me a little hair or whatever
I'll just I'll start with something
that's what that's what Travis's new
stepfather is that it's only fun today
tomorrow
[Laughter]
Travis is these are producers mom
abandon him several years ago and
abandon them in some way bunch of broken
orphans but you don't think that's the
way to talk to a girl Jim you're saying
no I'm just in general you just gotta be
like what I don't say call her a little
girl it's creepy what would you like
kiddo I'll use like sports terms for
like Little League hey slugger hey how
you doing Norton
that is there's nothing worse than when
a girl says like hey bud god damn it I'm
signal sending like what do you think
I'm [ __ ] a grown man I understand her
she's like a sister to me and then they
do [ __ ] such a lie never I've never once
even come close to [ __ ] my brother
don't tell me she's like a sister you if
you've already hooked up like three
years ago like that's the brothers do
you have a brother you see a very only
child
dr. Emily what do you think of the
friendzone dynamic we were analyzing in
a couple weeks ago one of our hot dog
again he works with us here he helps us
out and he's he's in a very very very
very bad friendzone situation you know
he likes the girl he won't admit to it
and yes he by the way he's not talking
to her neither she told me yeah but I
but we were trying to epidemic yeah
analyzed it and it's like the girl and
you see this a thousand times the girl
doesn't admit that she's getting all
this extra attention and whatever else
she's getting because the guy's in love
with her yeah and the guy doesn't admit
he's in love with her because it's too
humiliating so you got two Liars just
like we're just great friends yeah
exactly and he wants sleep with her and
she knows it but she loves it he's like
getting her car fixed they're like
listening to all of her problems and all
of emotions so here's the thing about
the friendzone is that it's hard to get
out of the friendzone but you have to
notice it because there's a lot of guys
that's another thing they're always in
the friend zone you could learn to kind
of get out of it because what happens is
nice guys kind of go in they meet a
woman and they're like oh I'm I'm gonna
be this is how I'm gonna get her to like
me I'm gonna be your friend I'm listen
to all her problems I'm gonna like help
her with her house and hang your
curtains and girls like that's great
he's helped me but there's nothing sexy
about that so when you get their love
language is not acts of service exactly
right even then but though that's
I learned right right you got a lot of
time on your hands only [ __ ] for
seven minutes I have lots of time for
hobbies is the thing it's like I can all
my activities none of them get
interrupted friend zones are bad though
is if you're dishonest about why you're
hanging out with someone exactly if
you're saying like no she's like my [ __ ]
the guys that are the worst because they
love the girl but they won't admit they
love the cry so how does it how you get
out of the friendzone is you recognize
that you're in the friend zone you make
it known as soon as possible that you
want to have sex with this chick that
you have to say like I'm attracted to
you and I want to I want to I feel like
this is more than that or you just say
like I want to kiss you if you've been
hanging out a few times you're like I
think it's going in the friends OB like
I really I just I want to kiss you but
that takes a lot of confidence that most
guys in this scenario don't have and
they're so scared right because they
want some kind of connection and the
first fantasy of the relationship and
she says my male friends should never do
this if she says no yeah but then like
you can't even have the friendship
article though they got to work this
muscle because they don't really want to
be there they're afraid of it there's no
[ __ ] friendship you want have sex
with you that is not a friend I've done
that before so it doesn't always work
when you're honest like I've tried how
did you know waste time how did you know
that it wasn't gonna work I just I
indicated to her that I was attracted to
her and she was not responsive how did
you indicate how about how about plant
in a smooch on daddy
and a friendship it's how you gained a
daughter Karen you strike me as somebody
that doesn't mind stringing a fella
along really yeah yeah I don't think so
I don't know I mean I don't you have you
have an intern he wants to sleep with
you
yes fixated on me as that I think he
should come get you soda I'm sorry
any like take pictures of me and he'll
like fill my sights he's good yeah he
definitely doesn't keep a copy of those
photos to them when he gets home yeah
right like it's a win-win yeah he knows
he's too young for me you know I don't
think he's really he might he might like
me but I don't think he's overly fixated
to the point that it's interrupting his
life how old is he
I think he's like I think he's like 21
but here's the thing about women we like
it though because we're like oh we want
our emotional needs met and it feels
really good to have a guy who's gonna be
there not so it's on both of us men and
women yeah we're like real honest life's
too short to hang out people when it's a
weird murky relationship here's how you
know as a woman that a guy is like it is
being dishonest if every guy you talked
about he bad-mouths oh yeah [ __ ] block
move hey I met this guy you [ __ ] lump
of [ __ ] energy yeah pretty sure you just
made up that rumor yeah
[Music]